so Gary Vaynerchuk was like my boss
essentially and you know I learned a lot
from him in terms of like I guess it's
just like always think like one of my
old bosses I used to work I was the
creative director at vaynermedia so Gary
Vaynerchuk was like not my boss
essentially you know I learned a lot
from him in terms of like marketing is
really just about day trading attention
like it's marketing is all about
attention and attention to it or price
the price for a billboard you're paying
so much per eyeball and it sees it it's
like yes it could be effective but
you're overpaying for it versus create a
yoga studio in LA
you might generate even more eyeballs
and attention at a way WAY lower spend I
think it's just always thinking about
who how do I get attention for my brand
and what are all the different possible
ways that you can get attention what's
like the most cost efficient ways to get
that and I have to ask was it awesome or
not awesome working for him is the guy
the real deal or what I love Gary I
think he's like an incredible human
being like you know I've worked for a
lot of corporate folks and I think
there's there's a lot of egos there's
people who don't care and I think Gary
like truly cares like even if you're
gonna tell him you're you're quitting
like he's gonna be like Oh awesome like
do you need any help finding your next
thing you know like he's just like he
cares I think that's what he's built his
whole company on is like you can build a
massive company with like a
compassionate point of view on your
people and not just being some like
tyrant kind of do you think there's any
anything about Gary cuz he's a very
public presence right he's personally
out there a lot and you know anytime you
person to put yourself out there cuz
it's putting a part of you out there not
the whole thing is there anything that
either people don't really know about
him or is a misconception that you've
seen about him is there anything like
that I would say that like just talking
like just talking with him normally one
to one is obviously the volume isn't as
loud as it is when he's on camera you
know very like he's an entertainer
to a degree right now he's an
educational business entertainer but
he's entertaining to watch like the way
he talks like how his passion is like
how he's smart like there's plenty of
business people who say smart things but
not maybe as many that are like so it's
like in a way he's kind of playing you
know a bit of his character but it's
like off-camera like he's way more
mellow I would say then most people
think like you know he's yeah I was on I
was I was on his podcast or like that I
forget whatever it's called and he was
very nice and I had we he turned it up
slowly but yeah he had he wasn't on
right away you know he had to get amped
a little that's awesome all right well
Mike we'll wrap it up
[Music]
[Applause]